and are we live okay so hopefully we're
now live and you all could can see us
welcome to Android design in action
travel booking and planning sorry for
the screw-up we're about five minutes
late
we're as you can see we're not in our
normal room today there is a scheduling
kerfuffle if you will anyway so let's
get started my name is Roman Nurik
Adam Kosh over in London we have hi a
Nick butcher yeah so we've got the three
of us here and today we're gonna be
talking about a couple of apps travel
all that have fall into the kind of
travel booking and planning category so
let's get started because that select
the slides there the first app we're
going to do is kayak and actually Before
we jump into this kind of forgot to talk
about what the show is all about since
this is only the fourth or whatever
episode of the show probably mentioned
in this show we don't really you know
review apps and and let you know you
know what the best apps are to go
download we basically look at a few apps
that have been nominated or submitted to
us for review by the greater developer
community and we take a look at how we
can spruce them up visually how we can
make some some improvements here and
there to the visual design and the apps
that are submitted are actually reviewed
the previous Friday in the app clinic
where Rado meyer and ian nee lewis
take a look at kind of a higher level
overview of the app and how the the
overall app can be improved but in this
in the show we look at the design
strictly and specific screens unit so
let's get started with client and just
to say and today we're having a special
focus on Thomas right well that's right
that's right so today we're going to be
talking about apps in the context of
tablet usage so you will not see any
phone screens as far as I know maybe
later later down the road where we talk
about design news but yeah we'll be
focusing on on 7-inch and 10-inch
tablets so for kayak we looked at the
the 7-inch tablet version so in this
case we have a nexus 7 and kayak is
basically
an app that lets you do lots and lots of
different things lets you you know look
for flights look for hotels look for car
rentals it's got a million features and
these are all awesome features the
feature set is completely you know broad
and expansive there's so much you can do
with the app but we chose to focus for
now on on the hotel search since that's
kind of one of the key features so in
this screen here you can't really see my
mouse pointer that's fine
oh you can't sweep in this screen here
you basically you know this is actually
two screens you have a dashboard which
is kind of the landing page when you
first open up a kayak on your Nexus 7
you have this kind of set of icons that
indicate the different sections of the
app and then you have kind of extraneous
or separate functionality things like
airline directory airline fees kind of
ran though assortment of other things in
the in the action overflow
once you select hotel search which is
kind of the sum this middle top middle
icon you get to a hotel search screen in
this screen you basically select you
know that they are check-in dates the
the number of guests number of rooms all
that type of stuff
when you press search hotels you're then
taken to a list or a map of hotels so
basically you can see here that to
search for a hotel you have to go
through three separate screens if the
you know firstly the dashboard then type
in some information about the hotel
you're looking for and then see the
results and possibly obviously going to
the hotel details so do you guys have
any thoughts on kayak in general or
these couple of screens and a couple of
thoughts so first of all I love kayak I
think it's a you know use the website
for many years so it's great that they
have a solid app one interesting thing
about these designs I guess is that they
sort of have they have the parts of
passive design best practices but other
parts are kind of just missing missing
the design best practices so you've kind
of got these uh you've got these
gradients you've got these you've got
some a semi action bar at the top there
faux action bar the photo action bar as
we call it and you've got the the drop
downs in
have a little triangle to indicate the
spinner but you know it's kind of half
in half and I don't even know if they
would need that compatibility menu
button down the bottom anymore because
they kind of have the faux action bar so
you're simply switching the target SDK
up might actually remove that Cody no
Nick
so my first thoughts when I look at it
is this says to me it's a web app
masquerading is a native activity and
there's some subtle hints you can see
the artifacts like the gradients and how
some of the screens clearly just been
stretched up to fill the canvas which
immediately sent me in a frame of mind
thinking that this app is going to be
perhaps slightly less responsive than my
hope and it might not follow the kind of
my my expected mental models certain
things like you can just get like the up
arrow next to the pop icon on the second
screen you can see it's slightly too big
slightly too thick all of these things
which it may seem very subtle but they
just hint the use of this app is gonna
function unlike to standard apps which
are used to functioning website already
like a you know I'm also a big fan of
Chi but already as if you're going on
yeah and actually just just let's talk a
little bit more about the faux action
bar there's really no reason to do it
anymore right and I think actually Jake
Wharton who's the author of one of the
greatest kind of action bar libraries
out there actionbarsherlock mentioned
you know you're doing a lot of work if
you're rewriting it yourself you're
doing a lot of work to try to get it to
look and behave like the rest of the
platform so there's really just no need
to do it since you know for backwards
compatibility purposes there are
libraries like actionbarsherlock that
just do the work for you it's really
just a drop-in right so it's there's
really no reason these days to do it
it's so style it's so customizable
pretty much everything about the action
bar is customizable so there's really no
reason to have to you know make your own
one last thing I want to talk about
before we jump into the redesign is the
branding so the branding throughout this
I do love the the color palette you know
there's a strong kind of orange dark
gray light gray color palette and I'm
personally a huge fan of single accent
color palettes where you have you know
grayscale plus and
accent it's really phenomenal and I
think that they you know they have lots
of opportunities to use that really
unique kayak orange throughout and I
think that you know what they have here
is is one possible way of doing things
but I feel like they can go even a step
further so let's jump into the the
redesign this is one possible way that
you can imagine a tablet version of
kayak to look so in the top you have
your standard action bar with there's no
real need for an up affordance in this
case because this is a single screen
you'll notice that we combine three
screens into one effectively at the left
you have the same kind of hotel search
and you know we've kind of redesigned
some of the elements to fit better into
the holo design the holo styling we've
also given more prominence to recent
searches this is something that Ian
pointed out last weekend app clinic
recent searches is something that's
that's really commonly used right I mean
you really want to have access you don't
want to lose something you just did
right so if you went into the app and
did a search maybe did another search
you would go back to the other one you
really don't have to rewrite everything
or re-enter all that information
essentially it's actually a property
like kayak which it has that rich web
property so if you're able to take that
search history from the desktop to your
devices as well that can be a killer
feature that can save you a bunch of
time like Google Maps does for example
yeah totally totally I mean sync is
that's like a in Russian we would say
some awesome way that's like a whole
separate story but sync absolutely this
would that would make this whole
experience just like seamless so yeah so
have recent searches you know simply
simplified the the entry form use icons
actually their phone version the phone
version of the app uses icons and tablet
version doesn't it seems kind of silly
to have to redesign in the same screen
across different or massively redo the
same screen across different different
form factors if you like in this case
they could have just you know combined
certain elements from vote and had less
work to do when porting to different
sizes but anyway so that's that's kind
of this screen you'll notice that we
it's
touch-ups on the map balloons or map
bubbles and things like that but one
question is you know what about core
navigation right switching between
hotels flights cards things like that so
for that we decided to use the the
action bar spinner navigation so
basically at the top level you start off
with hotels or whatever you feel is the
most common or most important you know
aspect of my app so you can start with
hotels or flights we also added
notifications since that was in the
phone version of the app and you can
also one one minor point is you can make
it sticky right so if somebody most
recently used flight search in kayak
then we know when they back out and go
about their daily lives and they open up
kayak again you can start them off in
flight search right it's totally up to
you where you start the user give a
strong indication that they're into
flights right now then start them up
there and then lastly you know you have
this kind of area on the right to put
extra functionality so in the action
overflow you can put things like you
know price alerts or packing list stuff
that's not really commonly used probably
me like five over ten percent of the
time so what'd you guys think so far
yeah I think I really liked it
two to one question first of all the
diagonal up pointing arrows by the
search history I gather that
pre-populates
yeah I think that's a great feature like
I use that all the time say for Google
search especially you know when you're
doing searches for hotels you might want
to just change the dates a little bit
you might want to tweak the location or
something like that so I think that's
great and the other thing I really like
is um kayaks sort of been traditionally
known for their it's a power of applying
filters mm-hmm but you know on a desktop
experience you can you've got a lot of
screen real estate to fit those filters
in immediately on a smaller device on a
mobile device or even on a smaller tab
like the Nexus 7 there's not as much
screen real estate so it's sort of being
collapsed into that action action button
at the top there I don't think you
actually mocked up how the filters would
look the nice thing is is that you know
the screen remains sort of clear and
easy to
and then engaging that can sort of
unfold the you know the power of the
kayak field is yeah so so filter is
actually in landscape in their current
app when you tilt it into landscape it
shows the filters as a left pane it
seems like I mean that that that's that
may make sense in general we try to
maintain something called functional
parity across portrait and landscape so
if you switch from portrait into
landscape your view of the world your
view of the app won't
drastically change and the things you
can do with the Apple drastically change
showing filters may be appropriate but
at the same time like filters is almost
is almost always is kind of a separate
action right like filter what you're
currently looking at or sort so if you
have both sort and filter for example
get a list here if you have both sort
and filter then you should probably you
know have those side-by-side since
they're very commonly used together let
me just quickly since we're kind of
running a long time we quickly jump into
this next screen so once you get into
the search results you know what I
thought here is on a 7-inch device you
know you don't you can't you can't
really show both you know the map and
its full fidelity and a left pane in
portrait side-by-side so one option is
you can actually collapse the left pane
into this kind of into this collapse
left pane I guess there's a better name
for it this is similar to what Google
Talk those and on a 7-inch or 10 inch
device and then if you're on a 10-inch
device and you have this space then you
never have to collapse or if you're in
landscape on 7-inch you also just don't
have to collapse
lastly you know I know we're running a
little low on time the last day I just
wanted to talk about this point that Ian
made actually I think either Ian or Eno
made this but last week they talked
about this this concept of let me book
my entire trip right if your kayak and
you have access to hotels and flights
and car rentals and stuff to see around
you and we'll talk about that a second
with Trip Advisor you know do more than
just give the user the option to choose
hotels and flights as separate parts of
the app you know don't necessarily
separate your app into separate sections
so what if you combine this entire trip
planning booking I
sinner area experience into one flow so
this is something that we mocked up here
where basically your sections are no
longer hotels flights and car prism
whatever your sections are now just your
trips this is kind of similar to what
trip it does in Tripoli has a great
model of you know of creating giving you
an itinerary right it shows you all of
your hotels cars and everything all in
one chronological flow and people are
really good at dealing with you know
time or chronological flows so in this
case we have the hotel search which is
part of this left pane which is
basically an itinerary so as you scroll
up you get earlier in your itinerary and
as you scroll down you get further down
in your itinerary so your your arriving
flight is above the hotel search which
is above the departing flight once you
find in booked a hotel that Hotel search
card in this case it kind of turns into
a hotel booking card and then you can
you know if you're not interested in
getting a car rent though for example or
a hotel you can just swipe it away to
dismiss it so what you guys think does
this make sense as kind of an itinerary
planning I want this that I love what
you've done here I mean I completely
agree what you say about the grouping
making sense to me kind of rather than
having to go in and out of different
apps or different sections of an app
they're kind of putting it on a timeline
instantly just I just get it and I
really like it and it must simplify your
work further as well I mean if I've
entered the dates of my flights I mean
surely you can infer the date of the
hotel stay as well and kind of grouping
it all together and makes that
completely obvious so I think that's one
of my major takeaways from this redesign
is the way you've simplified the
workflow to remove steps remove
dialogues and kind of have it easier to
access yeah totally and you open this up
to you know other possibilities right so
if in the future you expand to two
restaurants or something like that you
can add kind of placeholders for
restaurants let's say you know every
night of the of your stay or you know
right before your flight or you know
something like that you you have really
a lot of options of fully managing a
flight or fully managing your trip
actually one thing
a call-out is Adam and I were talking
about this and we struggled with how do
you add stuff right so we have this
extra action the top right that's kind
of like add a card but Adam you
mentioned like you know you can just
place that in line right yeah I mean
you've already got the and add car
rental there so I mean there could be
just an extra button or something that
triggers adding a sort of segment to the
trip either either way I mean that would
just be something that would be
discussed before actually enhancing this
but uh overall I like it yeah and like I
think that's that's the great thing
about you know this type of thing right
there's so many different options and
one thing we should caveat in it we
should probably get on such revisor
pretty soon but I think we should Cabot
is these are just you know visual design
mocks right you won't really know until
you know until you actually you know
have a prototype in your hands whether
or not all this really works but these
are just you know some ideas that that
we throw around so take it take all of
our ma to the grain of salt dates all
right so with that should we move on to
TripAdvisor name that's so first thing
you want to talk about what we see here
my messy desk so I've really enjoyed
doing this Android design in action show
where we're trying to quite quickly turn
around some redesigns from from you know
it's bringing around a few ideas on how
we might change things based on playing
with the app for a little while to turn
that into a mop to give you a good kind
of understanding what that might look
like so for me when the biggest
takeaways has been more sketching the
better the more time I spend in low
fidelity purse typing tools like you can
see here on my desk I find it saves me
tons of time down the road I am actually
in in Photoshop or whatever your tool of
choice is for producing high fidelity
box so here's a couple of examples you
can see other ideas I've played around
with and it's scribblings out and
refinements here there and everywhere
and it just saves you tons and tons of
time so I'd say paper/pencil sticky
notes are your friends here and for me
I've found as well bouncing ideas off of
someone else the minute you try and
articulate an idea to someone else you
find yourself sketching it out trying to
show it to someone it it gets so much
better than a Robin sitting down kind of
climb away on your own so it's been fun
you know just to call out a few episodes
ago
maybe in the second episode of the show
or maybe the third we we actually
provided links to some of the great
templates that you can download and
print out so you don't have to
necessarily start from scratch right you
can start from you know one to one size
templates that you can just print out
and start trying on so there's nothing a
good start I decided to just go straight
from from pen to paper starting from
scratch right yeah I found the templates
are great when you're trying to get a
consistency between screens because you
can get rough sizes of elements are
lining up to get get your that
consistency but if you just doing a
single screen I've been fine going even
even lower fidelity just a blank piece
of paper can be lighter weight cool
alright so let's move on to the app
itself so this is TripAdvisor and this
is the the dashboard screen thoughts
comments yeah so this is the first thing
you're presented with when you open the
TripAdvisor application on a tablet and
it's kind of sparse I mean we do a minim
advocate a kind of a minimal look and
feel but I feel like this is taking it a
little bit too far especially when you
consider their tablets might have a
slightly different use case I find well
most studies have shown that tablets are
using them much more kind of discovery
kind of mode when you're perhaps have a
longer engagement time and you're
looking for something a little bit more
engaging and as opposed to you know
perhaps a mobile phone experience when
you're looking for a snacking experience
to get in and out quite quickly so for
me this design fell a bit flat for for a
few things so there's the sparsity at
first next up is laying out all the kind
of different verticals which tripper
offers is it's kind of like exposing the
way that they internally classify the
information let me I know whenever I go
to the trigger service and I absolutely
like TripAdvisor service I absolutely
love TripAdvisor either all the time
easy to plan my honeymoons fantastic but
I never have gone and drilled down oh I
want hotels now I want hotels in the
East Asia or whatever I always research
like for me search is the key way and
you can navigate so I felt like having
the top line and
burst course called out was was kind of
almost like misleading and lastly and as
with most of these redesigns and it
doesn't quite fall into that like
natural Android look and feel and
already the the height at the bar at the
top is kind of non-standard there kind
of some there's some gradients
throughout the application and padding's
kind of off the text boxes aren't quite
as you might expect and then also
throughout the application I found lots
of lots of extra stuff which you kind of
get with all websites so for example and
it might be links to legal information
and privacy policies and so on that you
will quite often see in perhaps the
footer of a website but part of the
beauty of an ethics spirit you can
achieve by simplifying and really
concentrating on doing one or two things
really really well so I found there's a
lot of web metaphors which is being
carried over into the application
perhaps through reusing code in web
views for example that really distracted
from my experience and didn't really
offer any added benefit so we try to
kind of reduce those distractions I
never thought oh well I'm not a loss of
words that was very well articulated
yeah I think I mean this is almost like
similar to the Google search you know
what like Google com right when you go
in the web sites Google com you just
presented with a search box but you know
Google calm when you when you want to
Google something you generally actually
want to do a search right that's that's
kind of the one thing people think when
they think the average person they think
Google they think of search right but
for TripAdvisor to me at least and I'm
guessing most people they don't
immediately only think of search they
probably think of search as well as
discovery like you said right you know
like what what are the great things that
people are saying on TripAdvisor it's
it's a it's a network it's a community
right of of content right that's that's
rich in that that you may not really
know about you may not know what you're
looking for when you get to TripAdvisor
so bubbling that up I think is is very
important all right so I do wanna talk
about the redesigning in three two one
wow this is some lovely effects getting
on that Wow
okay so here is what I've done with the
the redesign this week and
so there's a couple of things we've
really tried to achieve the first off is
adopting the holo look and feel as we
always tend to do so you can see this in
the flat agreeance they're kind of the
use of the color palette while still
retaining the true provider accents it's
kind of a much more standard color pack
taking call of inspiration from the
Google+ app in fact and using standard
and like familiar iconography which the
users should instantly be able to go and
pick up on but what we've done here is
we've while emphasizing search so you
receive we've made the search box stand
out from the the rhythm of the rest of
the application to give it prominence as
well as like really enlarging it and
there's a huge kind of search box really
and as well as floating a relevant
content if you go to TripAdvisor this
website it's it's full of lots of kind
of discovery mechanisms so P that's
social from what your friends are up to
kind of curated lists or things you
might like to you might enjoy or like to
discover so we've tried to bubble up
that information so well well in that we
forced be retained the information which
is the most important to the user so
starting from the far left we have the
users information so they have this kind
of my saves area where you can save
information for later retrieval and as
well as similar to the kayak we've given
recent searches and less and more
prominence here as well
awesome yeah and then nearby right like
if you if you're near something that's
that's really important right you want
to bubble it up right so if you're if
you're on a tablet let's say in your
hotel in London in this case and the Big
Ben is having some sort of like event or
something or there's some sort of event
at the Big Ben clearly I know nothing
about 1 min event that's true so you can
kind of bubble something up like that in
a really visual way right I also love
actually this is very interesting what
you've done with the friends so this
activity stream where you know a friend
did something with a place right like
reviewed a place I like kind of the the
interesting spate or the interesting you
say
of that Squarespace where you basically
made two triangles overlapping this
actually quite it works quite well with
the opengl meshes as far as I know but
anyway it's kind of interesting to kind
of show a half half Avatar half
thumbnail of the place really
interesting treatment there yeah if you
look back a couple of slides of my messy
sketches you'll see a couple of post-it
notes of ways of doing that so I had
tried you know trying to pair these two
images together and you could have some
overlap or maybe have it slightly
indented but it ends up looking kind of
uneven and jagged so it was a suggestion
from a friend as you go for that kind of
thought I get a wipe or whatever you
want to call it and I like it cool and
it's just a couple of notes here like as
Roman said we're not going to be showing
any phone redesigns here you might end
up either reprioritizing or kind of
showing slightly different content on
the phone because there might be a
different context and users in like I
can imagine saying that my stuff the
reasons they might say is it's gonna be
a really prominent but some of the big
visuals might kind of be a bit too bit
too heavy for a phone you might want to
de-emphasize those slightly or perhaps
even not show them I think the approach
I've really taken here is thinking about
this from a tablet point of view so
you're thinking about these big visual
engaging experiences lots of visuals one
one other minor thing we're running
super low on time but I just really want
to call this out in general when
designing with photos some folks may
think oh my photo is like you know you
know certain aspect ratio so the UI
element also needs to be that aspect
ratio don't don't lock yourself in that
way especially for photos where the
subject is in the center feel free to
use something called Center crop which
is scale type on image views
we're basically you know you select the
aspect ratio and the image is cropped
within the UI element so you'll chop off
either the sides the the the left and
the right or the top and the bottom to
make sure that the image itself
maintains its aspect ratio while fitting
within the UI element so I think this
works really well for things like
avatars like people avatars where their
face is usually in the center and you
know photos of Big Ben for example
how much time I just want to say I like
it okay so let's move on to the the
detail yeah we did one more screen so I
see you're eating it was having so much
trouble in searching for Venice in the
app clinic if you caught it last Friday
we decided to take a little look at
Venice here so this is what happens when
you search for for Venice it just give a
generic kind of like city level result
and and it I think the original is a lot
better than the the landing screen I
think they're doing some good things
here they're showing some appropriate
information but I also think they have a
problem with the information density I
think they're kind of showing too much
information as well now I know for me
when I think TripIt of TripAdvisor cubes
in it when I think TripAdvisor I think
the beauty of the services in the sheer
number of reviews right it can give you
this very intelligently weighted list I
don't want to get a thousand results
which other search engines might offer I
kind of mostly interested in sending a
couple of filters and then just seeing
the top 5 or 10 and untrusting those
reviews or browse that reviews make sure
they're okay so I've already tried to
draw that out in the redesign here so
we've tried to deep isn't helping and
just float up the things which which
TripAdvisor just really about so you can
see in the design at the bottom here
we've retained the same kind of look and
feel so kind of flatter flatter look but
we've really bubbled up the user ratings
and you can see the ranking is given by
log prominence and with each listing on
the site and straightaway we've exposed
for each select for when you select
result you'll see that the graphs and
the photos and more information about
that place after yeah so that you've
given just more white space around all
the results on the left again I think
this is something I bring up fairly
often but use of white space is just
really important especially on tablets I
think that the bottom screen that you've
designed here just makes better use of
white space throughout all the three
panes that are visible cool I didn't get
time to muck it up this week but I was
toying with the idea of having like a
third pane off to the right as it were
so
when you were to click on those reviews
like the little bar charts or the photos
you could have that slide in and perhaps
perhaps collapse the leftmost panel and
think think what their Gmail doesn't a
tablet for example where you might have
your labels and the message subject and
then the message detail is kind of on an
axis which slides across I was thinking
something along those lines there but
didn't get time to mock it out
unfortunately just one very quick thing
is I'm looking at the the design center
from across the table on it on another
computer here and looking at them
side-by-side sort of small versions I
can't really see the text or anything
properly but the redesign just strikes
me is very clean and I can actually
almost make out like a lot of the
components even without being able to
see it see exactly what's there in there
so I think I think it the design like
looks it looks really good from that
perspective like it's very easy to make
out the most interesting pieces of
information
yeah generally good technique right you
know take your screen shot or or it's an
apk installed it and put the tablet you
know ten feet away from you and see if
you can roughly make out the structure
right you know if they're obviously read
the text because that's probably
impossible but it should it should be
clear to you what the screen does what
it's you know what its information is
about so here's so this is that seems
okay so since we're a super low on time
let's fly through Android design news
all right so first you honey Lynne Maki
released a book on Android UI called
smashing Android UI in collaboration
with Smashing Magazine I don't believe
that's shipping just yet the the
physical book but I think the e-book is
available on Google Play Books um I
think I think that QR code takes you to
the to the on Google Play Books for the
Google plate storage so check that out
super awesome
oh and Nick gets a mention in was it in
the foreword today johani recognizes the
awesome Google+ community cool next
somebody else wanna talk
the the books update anybody use books
actually don't really read books but
anyway okay fine so Google Play Books
the the official Android app was updated
and now uses actually the contextual
action bar if you long press and select
you know something from you know
something from the book like some piece
of text if it's a it's a location if
it's a place name then it'll
automatically do a google map search and
show you a little Google now style card
at the bottom with which you can then
click and you know get taken to maps for
she's pretty awesome you can also
highlight things and do cool things with
selections and play books
I think these cysts are really called a
really cool little UI flourish there
they it's like a zero kind of OneTouch
interaction it's not very clunky I don't
have to lump rare to copy air go to the
browser pace whatever it's just really
taking digital books and showing you
white digital book so more useful than
pistol books and I think it also speaks
to the fact that Google Books doesn't
really use too much skeuomorphic use it
meaning it allows for this kind of
interaction like kind of using that kind
of the very hairy scheme of crap Chicks
crutches kind of limit the scope of what
you can do what people how you can
extend people's very well-established
mental models so I think it's just a
really nicely done implementation yeah
okay oh yeah
so very quickly this is a this isn't
half full disclosure I've worked with a
Michael Potter before in the past but uh
that was a really neat little app it's
it's very it's about one purpose just
look up stop words it's it's a
implemented a design guidelines and holo
theming very nicely it's also about the
sort of card pattern which you see
around the place Claire what now and
that we talked about quite a lot with
these travel apps and yeah check it out
so it's very nicely done much to Mayan
NICs delight I believe Michael's using
either Roboto thin or Roboto light for
these backward I think it's just one
okay
delighted when you press this light up
all right I'm not just at the stock
price Nick you want to talk about the
Oakley redesign yeah so Marie strikes
again really feature
very designer than the ultimate
stopwatch app has spent one hour
apparently mocking up some redesigns of
the popular European travel app and
coffee I believe it's pronounced so this
is app I've used when I visited Berlin
this summer and found it quite hard to
use it was very dense and information
and she's really sprinkled with some
designers levelled over and just really
really helped with the information
density and the is so much easier to
read and cleaner I very much like what
she's done there so follow the link if
you want to read a bit more about that
one thing I want to call out is in the
right screen you kind of have shuttle
stops or bus stops that are connected by
a line with circles I think that's a
great way to tie together chronological
information you know you can just have
you know list items that it's a number
one or first and then next do this then
do that
but tying them together using a single
form using you know that line and then
the circles that's just an example well
I think that's a great way to time
together and and kind of further inform
the user that these are actually parts
of a sequence good job alright so that
does it for us I think we're about five
minutes late that's it's not too bad but
anyway thanks for joining
as always I'm Roman Nurik Adam Kosh and
I make book share don't forget to tune
in to the app clinic this Friday when
you can see which which apps are next in
line for perhaps being redesigned yeah
and like we said in the very beginning
we're gonna be focusing a lot about on
tablets this week so I believe they're
looking at tablet apps at that clinic or
the tablet versions of apps in that way
so again thanks for joining see ya later
bye